and we begin with this important warning
from president trump less than two years
ago he predicted accurately that joe
biden's economic policies would quote
unleash an economic disaster of epic
proportions well here we are record high
gas prices meaning the highest ever
anemic growth historic levels of
inflation a 40-year high in october
inflation was six percent when joe
became president by the way he inherited
uh 1.4
anyway in november it was even higher in
december even higher at 7
for the first time in decades and in
january a 40-year high at 7.5
now the february numbers came out just
today and now we're at a whopping 7.9
percent and it actually would be a lot
worse if you calculate inflation like
the federal government did under jimmy
carter before 1980 well if you
calculated using the old method it would
be over 16 percent either way all of
this inflation was recorded well before
vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine
before february 24th uh but according to
joe biden and jen saki they now have
they they're one thing that they can
blame on everything oh vladimir putin
it's all vladimir putin's poll high gas
prices vladimir putin today's inflation
report vladimir putin now this report
today is a reminder that americans
budgets are being stretched by price
increases and families are starting to
feel the real impact of putin's price
hike now today sake doubled down on
biden's big lie
and added an additional culprit greedy
oil companies let's blame them take a
look you may have noticed this week that
your gas prices have gone up i want to
talk to you a little bit about why a lot
of it has to do with vladimir putin
but part of this is on the oil companies
right now there are 9 000 approved
unused permits that oil and gas
companies could tap into now to ramp up
production the only way to protect the
united states over the long term is to
become energy independent that's why the
president has been so focused on
investing in clean energy technologies
so that we can rely on that and not
president putin to set the price of gas
well obviously jan saki is now
auditioning for fake news cnn or msdnc
she fit in perfectly if she keeps
telling lies like that you need to stop
lying this idea that putin caused last
year's oil and gas spike is a lie they
need to stop lying that putin caused
joe's 40-year high end inflation we had
that 40-year high before ukraine was
invaded by russia the most recent
numbers from last month russia invaded
ukraine february 24th as former obama
adviser stephen ratner points out quote
these are february's numbers and only
include a small russia effect four days
worth this is biden's inflation he needs
to own it but that's never going to
happen the new green deal socialist in
his own you know parties climate or
alarmist cult as i call it they want
more spending they want zero domestic
production of fossil fuels they own joe
biden they own gensake the propagandas
they owned kamala harris the
embarrassment and joey campaigned on all
of these insane policies you might
remember he told you he would do every
bit of this
if we don't stop
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't or
when they're deliberately put them in
jail kiddo
i want you to just take a look okay you
don't have to agree but i want you to
look in my eyes
i guarantee you i guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel and i am not
going to cooperate with them okay would
there be any place for fossil fuels
including coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated
all right this has always been their
goal this is their policy that was their
promise their promise is now being
fulfilled they know their energy
restrictions and rampant spending are
causing gas prices to spike they know
it's causing a 40-year high of inflation
they know that the average american
family is hurting because of these
policies but they don't care they care
more about their radical new green deals
socialist agenda now listen to this clip
from biden's energy secretary she made
these comments in november as gas prices
were rising then take a listen
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this as you know of course
oil is a global market it is controlled
by a cartel that cartel is called opec
and they made a decision yesterday that
they were not going to increase beyond
what they were already planning
now that was in november at the time gas
prices they were rising dramatically
jennifer grant home thinks it's funny
didn't care did nothing to increase
domestic production because that goes
against their stated policy look at this
new trafalgar poll by our friend robert
kaheli with russian oil ban from our
country a vast majority of americans
nearly 80 percent they want this country
to increase our own oil and energy
production but again the biden
administration doesn't care they're full
of excuses and the american people are
left holding the bag you're paying more
at the gas pump you're paying more to
heat and cool your home you pay more for
every product you buy at every store
that you go to and that's okay with them
they care more about their new green
deal socialist friends that obviously
have more influence in the american
people so let's face it they are not up
to the job economically and this is
hurting our national security on top of
everything else because now they're
willing to go what beg medura
in venezuela and go to the iranian
muellers and do
import oil from iran and beg opec that
keeps rejecting joe biden every time he
asks them to increase production
everyone knows joe biden is weak he is a
cognitive mess and they know that they
can do pretty much anything they want
now joe is either unwilling or unable to
travel abroad so he always sends kamala
harris in his place
and it just never goes well she's
obviously in way way way over her head
for example this week the vice president
in poland earlier today she doesn't
really seem to have any grasp on much of
anything it's pretty humiliating for the
country take a look you decide i am here
standing
here on the northern flank on the
eastern flank talking about what we have
in terms of the eastern flank and our
nato allies i want to be very clear
the united states and poland
are united
in what we have done
and are prepared to do
to help ukraine and the people of
ukraine
full stop we all watched
the television coverage
of just yesterday that's on top of
everything else that we know and don't
know yet
based on what we've just been able to
see and because we've seen it or not
doesn't mean it hasn't happened
but just limited to what we have seen
following those remarks trump's acting
dni rick grinnell friend of this program
tweeted quote oh dear god this is a
total disaster she is not prepared she
isn't grasping issues and solutions and
she rambles uh i blame the sacramento
media for never properly vetting her but
believe it or not it actually got worse
at one point the vice president that
means vice president harris responded to
a very serious question about refugees
with one of her world famous laughing
fits that's right the vice president
giggling before the world when asked
about what do we do with war refugees
watch yourself
is the united states willing to make a
specific allocation for ukrainian
refugees and for president duda i wanted
to know if you think and if you asked
the united states to specifically accept
more refugees
okay
a friend in need is a friend indeed
okay so this time
the war in ukraine let's see the
bombing maternity hospitals the leveling
entire neighborhoods
we have
mass graves with 70 people in it a
humanitarian crisis in eastern europe is
very serious
what are we going to do with the
refugees the stakes couldn't be higher
and europe is on the edge of a potential
world war that's got to be avoided and
kamala is yucking it up laughing it up
and giggling without any ability to
answer a simple basic question she never
gave an honest answer to that question
americans here at home abroad everybody
the world deserves better hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else